[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos en israel porque
científicos de la universidad de
tel-aviv imprimieron en 3-d el modelo de
un tumor usando células humanas de
pacientes enfermos con el fin de probar
la eficacia de nuevos tratamientos y ver
cómo se comporta antes de suministrar
medicamentos o terapias al cuerpo humano
wanting de tui identify what's the the
mothers e identificamos que los modelos
que usamos durante décadas son
incorrectos pues son solo de células
cancerosas en una placa de petri que
está hecha de plástico rígido y que no
tiene ningún parecido con el cerebro del
paciente o de personas en general lo que
queríamos crear es una placa
tridimensional en lugar de una placa
bidimensional donde cultivamos las
células en un gel que imita el tejido
del cerebro con mucha más precisión y
por lo tanto esto se traduce en el
comportamiento de las células cancerosas
later of the cancer cells en otras
palabras al estar fabricado con células
humanas el modelo replica el
comportamiento de esas células se trata
de un modelo tridimensional de
glioblastoma un agresivo tipo de cáncer
de cerebro el producto impreso incluye
un complejo sistema de tubos que
funcionan como vías sanguíneas y por
ellos fluyen tanto células como fármacos
con lo que se simula el comportamiento y
el ambiente de un tumor real
aquí vemos los vasos sanguíneos y lo que
está en verde son las células cancerosas
que los rodean
dentro de los vasos podemos ver las
células en rojo que construyen esos
conductos junto con las que los apoyen
incluidas otras células de ese
microambiente como las células
inmunitarias en el cerebro
y los expertos explican que el tumor
impreso se mantiene vivo aproximadamente
dos meses durante ese tiempo los
investigadores pueden probar diferentes
medicamentos contra el cáncer de una
forma mucho más precisa porque pese a
que las células se comportan de forma
diferente en el exterior a como lo hacen
dentro del cuerpo el modelo permite
replicar el ambiente cerebral por ello
aseguran que este producto es capaz de
imitar la tasa de crecimiento y el
comportamiento de cada tumor en cada
paciente para el estudio se tomaron
muestras de 80 personas con glioblastoma
cambiamos de tema y vamos ahora al mar
del norte para conocer el mayor parque
eólico flotante del mundo se llama a
wind scotland y se encuentra a 25 km de
la costa de escocia está compuesto por 5
turbinas eólicas gigantes que se
encuentran a más de 100 metros sobre la
superficie del agua y se mantienen en su
lugar mediante tres anclas que utilizan
succión
cada turbina está cubierta por sensores
que recopilan datos para ayudar a los
desarrolladores a realizar ajustes
tecnológicas
el peso de estas estructuras es de
alrededor de 20.000 toneladas y la
energía que estamos produciendo solo con
estas cinco turbinas alimentará
aproximadamente 36.000 hogares estamos
muy orgullosos del hecho de que tenemos
el primer parque eólico marino flotante
los responsables explican que la clave
para generar energía eólica es que haya
un suministro constante de vientos
fuertes esa es una de las razones por
las que escocia cuenta con varios
parques eólicos pero las ráfagas sobre
el mar del norte son más constantes que
el viento en tierra eso significa mayor
productividad y mejor rendimiento en
este parque
una de las cosas más impresionantes es
que con las turbinas flotantes es que
podemos establecer instalaciones más
lejos de la costa en aguas más profundas
esto es específico para reino unido pero
si miramos internacionalmente las
turbinas flotantes nos permiten apoyar a
otros países que tienen agua
extremadamente profunda cerca de las
costas así que si vemos países insulares
o incluso las costas oeste de eeuu como
ejemplo sabemos que tenemos aguas
profundas rápidamente wind y finalizamos
hablando de robots porque el
multimillonario fundador de tesla elon
musk anunció que su empresa trabaja para
crear el prototipo de un robot humanoide
se llamará 'the es la voz y estaría
disponible a partir de 2022
está pensando para hacer amigable por
supuesto por
navegar por el mundo tanto para humanos
como para eliminar tareas peligrosas
repetitivas y aburridas
lo estamos configurando de tal manera
que a nivel mecánico a nivel físico
puedas huir de él y sobre todo dominarlo
espero que eso no suceda nunca pero
nunca se sabe así que será una luz
se desplazará a 8 kilómetros por hora
en si puedes correr más rápido estarás
bien
el robot me dirá un metro 70 y pesará 56
kilogramos tendrá humanos con cinco
dedos vendrá en blanco y negro y contará
con una pantalla en lugar de cara así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]